I have been the CTO and founder of Cloud9
I have in the last two years thrown myself
at the GPU and using that thing for UIs and
doing interesting things.
And, the solution that I've arrived at is
called OneJS and I want to talk to you about
that today.
How many people here are graphics nerds and
how many here are language nerds.
Graphic nerds? Language nerds, good language
nerds are good.
Programming language nerds are good.
So OneJS ...
why?! Very simple reason, the GPU has vast
creative powers.
The programming languages‑‑ the programming
languages that can run on the GPU can determine
the color of a picks elwith a program not
with CSS background color or image, with an
actual program.
And what that means is that there is an enormous
amount of yee creative possibility that is
enabled by the use of programs on the GPU,
the only problem is, it is really hard to
do right now
's like a huge air grab between your UI programming
environment like JavaScript and the programming
environment on the GPU, which is GSL, it's
a C‑like programming language that came
out of Pixar, kind of sort of, but it's actually
kind of a pretty language.
It's pretty much just like JavaScript, if
you take out the objects, and you add instead
of numbers you can do vectors, so you can
do A plus B, and A is a vector and B is a
vector, and the result is a vector and every
component is added in parallel like Sim D,
and G P Us are everywhere nowadays, everybody
here is walking around with a GPU in their
phone that's more powerful than anything we
had on PC a decade ago here's my presentation
running on the iPad, it's sixty frames a second
on the web.
It's rally really nice that we have this kind
of GP U power vail northbound lane our mobile
devices, web GL is still kind of Shiy on Android,
actually really Shitty on Android, it's hopefully
going to get there some day when they fix
the GPU reset bug.
But, the main problem is that GL and GPUs
are really really hard, they're very difficult
and very, very elaborate to make them do things,
time just scrolling a bit of GL of web GL
AP I want here, it's incredibly chatty, you
have to do a lot of set up to get the GPU
to do something.
So, what is the essence of the GPU, how does
this thing work? You have to look at it in
a way that you can give it a program, a bit
of code that is computing fix elcolors, for
instance, and, you feed it data and variables.
And the variables are reference in the the
program and the data streams through program
in parallel and is then outputted to fix els,
I'm not going to go deep into the web GL explanation,
Steve Whiten has brilliant demos if you want
to understand how this stuff works, go look
at that.
I want to focus on how to remove all this
Kruft between programmer and the GPU.
So, one of the things that GPU can do is massive
par hash legaltion‑‑ this presentation
is running in OneJS because doing a talk about
graphics without using your own graphics engine
is kind of lame.
So, the cool thing about the GPU is that you
can feed it data and have these little programs
do your styling for you, so essentially you
par ram tar rise the data and then have the
little programs on the GPU do style switches,
do style changes, in this case I made a very
simple blob of vertex data, the little triangles
that go into the GPU, on every one of the
triangles is a letter, is a character of a
font, and in that big blob of data I encode
the XY coordinates, in this case the word
color is compute.
And that means that this whole thing is taking
like 0.2 milliseconds of draw time in JavaScript
and run entirely on yourBU, there's pretty
much nothing going on in JavaScript.
This parametertion of styling on to GPU, I
think is going to be very, very important
and it's going to find it, hopefully a new
way to style things on the web that CSS has
sorely lacked.
So the parialism idea or this picture is trying
to illustrate (Parallelism) you have to imagine
every fix elhaving a function call that computes
the function of the fix el.
In that case, the functioncal takes some arguments
an X and Y coordinate, exclamation parameter
T, and it decides the color of the text or
the color of the "I" el, it's same concept.
So, we all love of brad vector talks Whoo‑‑
that guy's awesome.
He had an interesting point about first principles,
it was a bit puzzling to me, first principles,
what are those things, this time around I
try to find my first principles of what I'm
trying to build.
And, one of the core concepts that I tried
to put in to OneJS is programmable beyond
configurable.
Programmable is better than configurable.
We all know the declarative space where everything
you want needs some implementation from an
engine designer.
We want another parameter to do something
in the engine, if you do it declaratively,
then those declarations have to be excueded
by an engine that somebody has to build.
We all know CSS spec stuff where is configurable.
But configurability is an enormously limiting
factor on the creative potential on what we
can do with computers.
But this concept, if‑‑ so, I usual live
apply like this, if you find yourself making
something configurable, consider making it
programmable, so instead of making an API,
make a Compiler.
Right.
Instead of having a flag using an expression.
At the very least an expression and better
general function execution.
And I try to put this in the details of OneJS,
another one is that style and behavior orer
reducible.
By this I mean‑‑er reducible‑‑‑‑
Irr deucible.
I'm encoding a red rectangle, I have to say
it's red and I have to say it's a rectangle,
I cannot make a red rectangle out of anyless
data.
Red button is the same thing.
Everybody here has probably made a button,e
in HTML‑‑ that logic is Irr educ Ibl
oh, if you're trying to introduce a button,
the language is completely Irreduc Ible T
only way to make UI more compact in the power
of expression is by composition.
Make composition the core aspect, programmability,
composition, because style and behavior are
Irredu doctorible
's no pipe dreams about let's make the grand
unified UI kit, because someone is going to
want the slide tore do something that you
didn't program into it.
So declarative is always going to break down.
And, this is something new that has arrived
with theGPU, inefficiency is okay when it's
parallel.
Many of you might think the GPU is so fast,
well, it's not fast,it's parallel.
Which means that it can run thousands of little
programs that run relatively slowly but you
can still get a vast result out of that that
you wouldn't be able to do if it's a serial
language, because JavaScript has pretty much
been a serial language, we're all accustomed
to four loops are expensive, well, if you
do it in par are legal you can do quite a
lot of things.
So, (Parallel) so how are we going to attack
this problem? So if you want to make theGU
programmable in a way this is more accessible
from within another programming environment,
because we oar not doing declarative structures,
we're doing programming environments and Compilers,
we have to fuse GSL‑‑ GLSL into JS as
much as we can.
It's a language with strict typing you have
a four vector you have a float, and you have
an array of this and Ie an array of that.
And JavaScript, actually sin tackcally is
fair live close to what GLSL looks like in
terms of C, what I try to do was fuse these
languages at the hip, probably.
But, fuse them in a way that you can leverage
the same syntax whether you're writing a shader
or whether you're writing something that run
in JavaScript.
So, by the way, these are syntax shaders,
syntax highlighting is kind of lame (Laughs)
which means that I actually throw the AST
on to theG and you can write little fragments
that style your code.
I wrote a code editor with my previous company,
this was just like you want this, I don't
know why you want this, but it's awesome.
It's not about why, it's about the potential
of exploration that you can do.
If I can make an error jitter in my line of
code, I can add something that is useful.
This is not useful, but this looks pretty.
So OneJS is JavaScript, I try not to explain
JavaScript, that's annoying because I have
to explain a million times why I did something.
At the same time, trance Compiler I tried
to fix some of the problems that are in JavaScript.
And one of the things is I finally got rid
of semi colons, it's very important.
Visual noise, and I don't like visual noise.
But what you is to do to get rid of semi colons
is make it new line sensitive when it reads
parens or square brackets on the next line,
if you make it new line sensitive, at that
point, then you can get rid of semi colons,
no, semi colons are there for a reason because
it blows your foot off if you do it incorrectly.
Oh, now it's a cull of a sud b, shit, everyone
that's learned that‑‑ well, if you can
fix that, it's no problem.
And I tried to take the Ecma script 6 and
7 all the things I could find in coffee script,
Julia Lisp, I tried to fuse it down to something
that wouldn't break JavaScript but would still
add the stuff I needed.
If you're fusing two execution domains, there's
something that is very useful about symbolic
expressions, we'll get to that next, I'll
first show you the class, because classes
are another very important aspect of the language.
Because, offed‑‑ because of the composability
if you have a button, and you want to specialize
it to do something different, you need to
be able to inherit the class and change one
parameters, that's the most come pressed rep
evennation of that idea.
Button that's a different color, we'll take
this button and change the color, that's sort
of like a compression algorithm in your expression
of code.
Class is super important, I took‑‑ script
I changed one thing, they're not functions
anymore, I hate dot prototype‑‑ nobody
gets it, it's horrible.
So I just removed that prototype, my classes
are just objects, I don't have a new operator,
I have dot new.
I tried to explain it so many times and it's
just not going to work for me.
Doesn't mean it's not compatible with JavaScript,
because it's a super set, largely, except
if you like to do function call with parens,
on the next line, then that's your problem.
So, the interesting part is we have struts
and vector in this implementation, and we
have symbolic expressions, symbolic expressions
is an idea from lists where you quote and
you write something in code that looks like
code, but it's actually an ASD node in the
language, so here on the right you see X is
Y plus one, but with a colon if front of it.
The colon is the quote operator, the colon
eats the whole expression to the right and
turns this into an Astnode, you can now start
to treat expression as usable objects in your
language.
And heres an example of how you draw a triangle.
This is not library that abstracts away what
you do, these are the actual it's the actual
data, the differentiator and fixable differentiator,
there's no matrix stacks, there's no nothing,
this is just thest seasons of what the GPU
needs to draw a fry angle.
You can make a vector two array, so you can
use that in JavaScript, this compiles to a
flow 32 array expansion, so you really in
JavaScript here, I could a console log in
the middle, this is just JavaScript, except
it has a few little syntax tweaks, another
one of the syntax tweaks is the identifier
curly syntax, because I always get very annoyed
when I have to express tree structure in a
sort of computable way that I have to go toJON
or I have go to XML, which‑‑ (JSON)
which is horrible) it shouldv a construct
to express these tree structure in a way that
you can mix et with your language, like a
templating structure.
I could put a four loop in front of draw and
it would do it ten times.
So, this identifier curly syntax is actually
a call, it's object.call, and the curlies
are a function, so this just says device.call
wrap with function.
That's what it expands to, and it passes in
to this, because that is another important
thing, OneJS does not have global, it just
slaps this dot in front of anything that would
be a global, which means you access properties
on your object without using this dot, which
also makes your code much less wide.
So here we have a triangle, and you can see
the mesh with thementty brackets, that pull
in the data from the JavaScript space,I adopt
have to write attributes and uniforms, it's
generated for you (I don't have to write)
by looking at what you're using in the shader,
it's very simple, Compilers do it all the
time, something that needed to be done.
So, we have‑‑ we have device and we
have draw, and draw is just a draw call, but
if we can inflater a device and make a scene
and we can inherit from draw and make a layer
we can use composability to use actual scene
drafts, this is terribly ugly because a week
ago it did nothing.
This is a very simple example of how you do
nested rectangles with matrixes, right.
Scene graphs work in a way that you have a
reck tang that will has a matrix and then
something inside it that has a matrix, and
matrixing are multiplied together to get the
relative offset, that's how the CSS transforms
work, that's how the browser does it.
That's how you do 2 D nested transforms by
Concaptina theing the matrixes‑‑ simple‑‑
just implements the multiplication of the
matrix, you parameterize that matrix with
WH and SX, I could call it top, bottom, left,
right, all those kind of things, I like 'em
short, anybody can change that and make a
long name for it.
And, here you can see instead of background
image, you actually just make a texture fetch
and you do background.sample at a certain
coordinate.
So this rectangle can be parameterized any
way, I can twirl it, flip it, I can do anything
with the code, it's programmable, the styling
is programmable, the styling comes from your
class model, I can do inheritance, I can do
CSS‑like style class that are just applied,
just apply these properties.
Because shaders are now composeble, I can
reference an object, I can reference another
function on my class, essentially shaders
have been fused with the class model.
I have to hurry up.
So interactivity, this is really lame, but
it shows you a very important aspect of changing
stuff dynamically, so, on mouse left down
I change the symbolic expression of X to mouse
X and Y, so I lock it to the mouse.
Essentially the Compiler goes you've changed
an expression, let's recompile your draw function
and send it to the renderer, then the renderer
does the stuff with the mouse coordinates,
so I've essentially told the render today
that bind, this is expression day the binding
in the renderer by using a Compiler.
And, it's rally cool, you can change any part
of your shader function and variables interactively.
I'm still working on the animation system,
and all that, but we'll get to that later.
So these slides are written using a class
DSL because you have the nesting curly identifier
syntax, you can impresent a DSL by putting‑‑
by making a bunch of nested classes, you can
do class deck and a slide is in a deck, this
just means that can only exTennesseeuate a
slide because it's only known on the class
deck.
So if I don't put the slide thing p deck,
it's just going to say undefined.
So now I have a domain specific language that
is encoded in a class hierarchy, so, you know,
I don't need all these really fancy HTML things,
I can make a domain specific renderer for
these slides, the slide are aDM tree,but a
different kind of DOM, it doesn't reverend
all their children and I'm hiding layer, a
DOM tree is having a custom draw command I'm
going to render the current slide and nothing
else, I know slide ID, you specialize the
draw I differential,instead of being C + +
parameterized, it's a programmable engine
that has a per node draw calls that you can
just change.
So, the stuff not ready for use at all, three
months atwo let's do JSConf 2014, it's a nice
dead line if you're building Compilers to
get somewhere.
It's rally far to hello world when you start
with a language.
But, I still need to refactor‑‑ this
is a type inferencing Compiler, it's kind
of my first type inferencing Compiler, I need
some refactorring time on this thing.
It's multithreaded, so the code that you saw
runs in a worker, and the Compiler sends the
draw calls, the draw code to the main thread
which is really nice, because I don't get‑‑
or I get minimal garbage collection hick ups
in my rend E.
all the user stuff that's doing data generation
for data visualization or whatever it's doing
is not in the render thread, it's perfectly
fine had a work e.
It's fairly large, it's 130 K over the wire,
I'm compiling everything in the browser always,
I'm using browser based local storage to cachee
cache the output.
I don't like server based compilation solutions,
it limits the composability of your programming
construct if you is to precompile everything,
so it always compile in the browser, it's
actually really fast.
The whole slide takes about 450 milliseconds
to parse and compile the whole thing, which
is okay for about ten or fifteen thousand
lines of code in JavaScript.
And if it's cached it starts up much quicker.
So IOS is great, I was like, yeah, year, web
GL, bam, it's work: Android is web GL, web
GL, it doesn't work.
The state of web GL is not that great for
mobile yet, this is great that it works but
on Android it's not‑‑ you to manually
enable it in chrome or you can freeze the
whole operating system, that's why it's disabled,it
makee makes sense it's disabled, this is a
future facing technology, this is not something
you want the use for a corporate client any
time soon.
So, the future is constrained layouts, and
I have it running and because I have the Compiler
I can actually, you can just write a constraint
straight in your code block like this.
And it can run the solver on the scene graph.
So that's coming.
This is all not responsive and has no layout
engine because I haven't gotten to that point
yet.
But, I mean, I got a way with it because I
have essentially expression layouts so you
can do parent width minus a hundred, so position
something from the right.
It doesn't actually have layout engine, but
it will.
And I'm going to build a live code editor
in this thing itself, this is a great way
to build a code editor if you can do this
kind of text stuff.
But also the reason is that I need to bolt
editor on to the ASD directly otherwise the
editor is going to be this dumb thing that
looks at regular expressions which is not
you want to be with the code editor, you want
the full ASD, and operate on the SAD so it
needs to sterilize into proper code, which
is what I'm going to work on next and it needs
to work on this thing, the Oculus at 75 hearts,
I'm hoping the browser guys can get that done,
I'm fearing it might not happen.
It has almost no AI expotion, so I can writtene
run it in node just as well as in the browser.
And I'm going to, you know, make a prototype
of a new Cloud9 UI, I think it should be easily
doable.
It's on GitHub, you look at it and not complain
about it.
I mean, you can look at it and do stuff with
it if you want, not something I'm throwing
out in a supported way, because I'm in the
middle of, you know, bolting the time inferencing
Compiler into a code editor, I need my brain
time for that, instead of support everything,
yet.
I believe if I have that editor support is
going to be a lot easier.
This actually runs on hello.onejs.IO you can
open it up and blow your battery power.
It's expensive.
You need to stop animating this stuff, it's
great if you want to burn through your battery,
you need dirty regions and not animate.
This is by the way, you can just throw your
ender scene to win amp kind of visualization
in five minutes, because the composability
is super easy.
A good friend of mine, just before I went
to JSConf was like let's put pack tills ton
outlines of your font.
I was like Dude ...
really, it's not useful, but it's so fucking
pretty.
Right.
(applause) so, that was timed better than
I hoped, I'm done, thank you (Applause (If
you have ideas and questions, anything about
this, seek me out, I really do want to engage,
I just need my time to do some of the hard
bits in this thing, still.